listen man uh you actually I actually
saw you on one of my favorite shows man
Sex in the City
and I was like oh [__] Bobby Lee yeah so
that was bad no you're great but it was
one that's truly one of my favorite
shows why wow do you like this new
version of it I can't [__] stand okay
and I've been with them for the whole
six seasons yeah the two movies after I
even own the pink velvet uh six season
DVD case
why you're writing oh the writing is
good yeah yeah music yeah yeah here's
why I don't like the new boot the the
reboot yeah one you ain't got Samantha
yeah so the band's not really there yeah
yeah two you killed off my [__] big
so that bothered me yeah and now here's
the third thing wait isn't Aiden back
now yeah being big I know but I was
always an Aiden Stan yeah but big was
the dude but listen here's the other
thing it's just a shocking that you're
the socket oh Miranda uh Samantha's I
don't mean Racers I thought maybe the
wire you would have said it or whatever
and you know what I think that's one of
the most overrated TV shows
wow I love it I fell off after season
two yeah yeah but um
the third thing that I don't like is
it feels like an agenda to me uh Cynthia
Nixon who's gay in real life
on the show was as straight as an arrow
her character Miranda was always
business she would be the character of
the four that would be most likely to go
not saying she's hating on gay people
but that ain't my Lane but now it feels
like they made her girlfriend she gave
her a girlfriend and all of a sudden
she's gay and I'm just going this to me
feels like an agenda if you had
established within the show during its
run I love that she was bisexual then I
can't okay I could buy that but she was
so straight now you telling me she got a
girlfriend because Samantha had a
girlfriend
but that's Samantha's character you're
right you're right Samantha would do
that you're right Samantha was all over
the place that was her energy oh my God
oh my God
you're so passionate Miranda got married
to Steve at Brady right they moved to
Brooklyn Brooklyn yeah and I don't know
anyone's name I show up on set I don't
know who's wait why don't you tell your
Samantha story
Kim Cattrall your your best friend are
you friends with Kim Cattrall no
I'm not friends with her she was just no
I know I've already told the story too
many times on podcast but just and for
the records I don't want to get in
trouble
gay people Mazel Tov have added babies
I'm just saying like y'all feel like
y'all doing this to be hey we're part of
the times we're hip we're treating her
it feels forced yeah because that wasn't
her character right so anyway
um wow anyway I did a commercial and she
wasn't really not at night but it was
I'm gonna be honest with you yeah and
this is exactly from what he was saying
I wasn't good that day and during the
commercial so I did a commercial even
before I did Mad TV with Kim Cattrall
and I just wasn't good she wasn't nice
to you and as soon like I did five or
six takes Michael Bay directed it oh
[__] and I did five or six takes on
something what commercial was this Pepsi
with me me and Eric Stone Street were
towel guys for Kim Cattrall wow right
and um I wasn't good that day and in
retrospect why would anyone be nice to a
guy that's just like so nervous and
fumbling the ball you just proved my why
I was I know that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying she what she did
was she walked up to me and Eric Stone
said at the end of the day we're
standing together she looks at because
Eric sometimes we killed it you know
someone straight right no Modern Family
he's on Modern Family he's the fat gay
guy on Modern Family okay okay Stone
Street killed it and she walks right up
to Eric and goes you have a bright
future and then she looks at me and she
just walked away
was it one of those looks where it was
like yeah she letting you know without
saying it I think so yeah wow and I just
remember my heart shattered in my inside
my body right but in retrospect I was
terrible I remember I did Conan yeah uh
I forget what time many times I had done
code like seven times forget which time
I had done it but uh Sarah Jessica
Parker was on before me so I saw her in
the dressing room and I [__] melted
it's like you were one of my on one of
my favorite shows oh my God Carrie I
don't I don't know I don't think you
should be with patrons